Just on the way out, we were shown something really special.
This is what Raman used
to carry in his overcoat pocket.
It's his personal spectroscope.
So whenever he saw something interesting,
a flower, a rock, whatever.
He could look through this and see the spectrum with its colour.
This is really special because Raman
is most famous for his work on
spectroscopy,
and here is his personal spectroscope.
The thing that he really carried around
and valued.
It's like Isaac Newton's telescope or
something like that.
This is as close as one can get
to a scientist who's sadly died.
Here you can see the tools that he used,
not when he was doing big experiments,
but when he was relaxing.
You can imagine him: 'Look! Nice flower'
and then go, looks at it, so we're very privileged.
This is something I hope all of you who're watching will remember.
So this is the citation,
and here is, you can perhaps guess, is the medal.
Wow, if I put this near the lamp.
Well I wouldn't, I've never tried it.
There it goes, it's whizzing around, that's fantastic, that's really good.
I've never tried that, that's a first.
You did sound a bit alarmed, I was like, 'Oh no, what have I done?'